después de 18 meses con un escenario
vacío las luces el público y las plumas
están de regreso en el mulá gul
nunca había permanecido tanto tiempo
desde que el teatro fue destruido por un
incendio en 1915
finalmente de vuelta en el escenario los
bailarines sienten una mezcla de emoción
y alivio
me siento lista para regresar de nuevo
al escenario tuvimos tres meses de
ensayos entonces estamos preparados para
volver nos sentimos en forma y fuertes
así que sí
el things ayer durante esta larga
inactividad los 60 bailarines del
cabaret se quedaron en casa pero dieron
lo mejor de sí para mantenerse en forma
sabiendo que un día regresarían a sus
rutinas exigentes durante la cuarentena
nos preguntamos podremos regresar a
nuestra fortaleza de antes nuestros
cuerpos mantendrán su línea después de
una pausa tan grande y nos dimos cuenta
de que está bien sé cómo hacerlo puede
hacer el cancán de nuevo
[Música]
inaugurado en
1889 el mulá gul es conocido como el
lugar de nacimiento de la forma moderna
del baile cancán con capacidad reducida
y medidas de distanciamiento está listo
para fascinar a la audiencia de nuevo en
las reservaciones va muy bien para
septiembre las hemos abierto desde junio
esperando que la gente regrese y piura
motriz
el show debe continuar
[Música]
[Aplausos]